[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt vegetarische
köpfte dass es eigentlich ein
widerspruch weil köster bedeutet so viel
wie fleischgericht aber es gibt ferlach
kräfte und da wird einfach das fleisch
quasi ersetzt durch weizen kürze also
erkennt vielleicht auch unter dem namen
boko und haben seit mir grad für super
spannendes erzählt nämlich das ja und
dann habe ich gegoogelt und der
villacher ist das deutsche wort dafür
heißt auch in der damaligen zeit eben
übersetzt bauer bzw arbeiter und das
fand ich eben super interessant aber
jetzt komme ich nicht drum herum euch
hier erst mal zu zeigen wie das ganze
funktioniert wir nehmen jetzt hier als
basis erstmal weizen größe fein das ist
das wenn die türkische markt nimmt dann
findet ihr das unter dem begriff ist
nämlich so ein bisschen verbreiteter bei
den türken sag ich mal
und das gibt jetzt hier zuallererst mal
in eine schüssel eine große schüssel
gibt da abgekochtes wasser dazu das ist
noch sehr heiß so einmal mit dazugeben
ganz kurz verrühren und dann einmal mit
dem mit irgendeinem deckel oder hier wie
ich es mache mit dem teller abdecken und
15 minuten ziehen lassen
nach zehn minuten konnte das ganze hier
schon mal ein wenig vor sich hin quellen
und jetzt geben wir weichweizen gries
dazu und das quält dann so in der rest
hitze und ich gebe auch schon alle
anderen zutaten mit dazu haben wir hier
einmal mehr noch mal für die bindung ein
ei ebenfalls für die bindung und jetzt
habe ich halb und halb paprika und
tomaten markt findet das paprika mag ich
noch mal so schön geschmack mit
reinbringen es gebe ich jetzt auch noch
mit dazu und an gewürzen brauchen wir
nur salz und kreuzkümmel gemahlin
kreuzkümmel und anschließend reibe ich
noch eine zwiebel rein und dann kneten
wir das ordentlich also es dauert schon
so 10 15 minuten
ihr könnt auch in der die bay bridge zu
hause habt einfach mit der bosse 15
minuten rühren lassen das geht auch aber
ich habe gedacht für alle diese nicht
haben zeige ich es auch mal mit den
händen
[Musik]
ich mag das immer gerne so dass ich mir
dann den teig quasi aus der schüssel auf
ein backblech gebe und dann richtig
ordentlich knete gehabt nämlich
ausreichend viel platz und noch ein tipp
von mir fällt ihm merkt dass die masse
ein bisschen zu trocken ist einfach ein
bisschen warmes wasser noch nach gießen
immer höher also nicht so viel auf
einmal
und wenn ihr dann kleine kügelchen
formen könnt oder dass die brücke lich
oder trocken aussehen dann habt ihr
alles richtig gemacht also so sieht das
aus wo ich das ein bisschen flach nimmt
den kleinen finger und drücken eine
kleine mulde rein und das machen wir es
mit dem ganzen tag
so ich hab es auch helfen
handschuhe angezogen weil ich habe ein
paar haare mehr als gegenpart la niña
die menge es gut einfach nur zu einer
kugel rollen weil das jetzt wirklich
läuft dann so ganz anders ist die
schönheit perfekt ein bisschen flach
drücken und dann mit dem kleinen finger
eine mulde reinmachen
das ist klar machte dass mal weiter nach
dem kaffeetrinken
wieso habe ich gemacht ich hab ja lust
marie heute hast du schnell den geist
aufgegeben
das ging ja schnell so jetzt haben wir
alles geformt haben sie hat mir
natürlich auch richtig gut geholfen und
jetzt hier wieder rapsöl in einer pfanne
war jetzt machen wir die soße dazu so
einfach ein bisschen ruhe rein und jetzt
kommt's knoblauch zum einsatz ich mache
das gerne so ich gebe knoblauch einmal
in die tomatensauce und später das zeige
ich euch auch zum joghurt und deswegen
gewiss nicht in den teig weil dass er
doch ein bisschen zu spät daher hier
nochmal den knoblauch rhein geben und
auch richtig schön andünsten
[Musik]
zum knoblauch dem wir dann noch paprika
mark und braten das noch so ein bisschen
darin an und löschen das ganze mit
geriebenen tomaten das heißt ich
schreibe einfach tomaten die sehr reif
sind ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel
tomaten aus der dose nehmen und dann
löschen wir das noch ab mit etwas wasser
sollte schon so eine flüssige masse sein
und salzen und pfeffern natürlich und
wer mag kann es zum schluss noch ein
bisschen olivenöl für den geschmack dazu
geben
das mache ich ganz gerne und jetzt
können wir die soße auch schon beiseite
stellen wir brauchen wir gleich erst und
wir machen jetzt hier einmal alles
fertig das heißt einmal salzwasser
aufkochen und die keller kräfte sind
also die christlichen die jeweils
kügelchen einfach reingehen und das
dauert so ungefähr zehn minuten bis das
ganze sogar ist und ihr merkt es auch
daran dass das ganze dann an die
oberfläche steigt
[Musik]
bei mir haben sie jetzt ungefähr 18
minuten gedauert also ein bisschen
länger als die angegebene zeit weil ich
die schon ziemlich groß gemacht habe das
setzt normalerweise vor anderthalb
jahren gemacht da waren sie noch sehr
klein dann brauchen sie auch mal zehn
minuten aber wir können zwischendurch
auch eine mal rausnehmen anschneiden
schauen ob alles schön da ist die dürfen
auch nicht zu weich sein und jetzt
einfach in die vorbereitete tomatensoße
geben und da ziehen die auch noch mal
ein bisschen wasser ein
so einmal schön schwenken und dann sieht
das auch viel appetitlich aus weil die
schmecken wegs extrem lecker aber ohne
soße schaut mal wenn ihr jetzt müsse mit
der sauce benetzen sieht viel viel
appetitlicher aus
[Musik]
und das war auch schon fertig ist das
köstliche gericht unbedingt nachmachen
und traditionell gehen wir natürlich
petersilie ganz ganz viel petersilie
oben drüber und ich freue mich schon
dass nachher zu verspeisen
ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel freude
beim nachkochen und tut mir eingefallen
abonniert jetzt also spätestens jetzt
main kanal wenn ich nicht schon längst
getan habt dann verpasst ihr nämlich
auch nichts mehr aus meiner ramadan
reihe
ihr dürft ihr gerne auch noch eure
wünsche äußern wir haben nämlich noch
nicht alle videos gedreht wir sind noch
flexibel
daher schreibt mir gerne euren wunsch
rein was darf nicht fehlen
jetzt aktuell natürlich eher
orientalische zutaten ob süß und herz
oder herzhaft ist egal wir sind sehr
flexibel na ja also ganz viel freude und
euch noch einen wunderschönen tag und
bis zum nächsten mal auf die gis kitchen
schinden
[Musik]